one of the most striking features of
relationships
is that after a while if things are
going well one or both partners will
almost naturally
start to refer to the other as baby
they might alternatively or in addition
stick a diminutive onto the end of their
name
e buy them a teddy or show them their
own from way back
and late at night speak to them in an
unusually high pitched soothing and
sing-songy way
we all invest a considerable part of our
energy and our pride in growing up
in ensuring that we no longer need help
in tying up our shoelaces
don't need to be reminded to wrap up
warm on cold days and can take care of
combing our own hair
in short we try very hard to be adults
but successful grown-up relationships
demand something rather peculiar of us
while we are rewarded for the overall
maturity of our characters and way of
life
we are also invited when striving
properly to be close to someone
to access the less developed and more
pure sides of us
it belongs to authentic adulthood to be
able
at points in an intimate relationship to
curl up like a small child
and seek to be babied as one might have
been many decades before
when we wore pajamas with elephant
prints on them and had a lisp and a
small gap in our front teeth it belongs
to health
rather than pathology to realize how one
might at difficult moments
want to be mummied or daddied by a
partner and to connect for a time with
the helpless
frightened dependent child one once was
and at some level
will always remain sadly though
this selective regression is no easy or
charming journey back for those whose
childhood
involved them in scenes of petrifying
suffering and humiliation for them
growing up has involved a superhuman
effort never again to place themselves
at the mercy of those who might take
advantage of their vulnerabilities
returning into imaginative contact with
mummies and daddies
therefore holds no particular charm
their teddies will not be having a
picnic anytime soon
these bulletproof characters are likely
to walk through the world with defiance
and strength
they will have built a heavy shield of
irony around their hearts
sarcasm may be their favorite mode of
defense and they will have ensured in a
thousand ways
that no one would ever attempt to ask
them even in the briefest
most light-hearted and humorous way to
come to mummy or daddy
for a hug the defensiveness is hugely
understandable
but it is not necessarily aligned with
the real requirements of maturity
true health would mean recovering an
easy and informal contact
with one's less robust dimensions it
would mean being able to play the child
because one knew one was resolutely the
adult
it would mean being able to be baby
because one was in no doubt
that one had safely overcome the fears
and traumas of the defenseless past
the more difficult the early years have
been the more our undeveloped self
must be disavowed the more we must
appear grandiose
impregnable and daunting nevertheless
we will know we have acceded to genuine
adulthood
when we can hold out a protective hand
to our frail younger self
and reassure them that we will from now
on be their reliable guardians and
protectors
and allow them to visit us for a cuddle
and a play
whenever they need to
love is a skill that we can learn our
relationships book
calmly guides us with calm and charm
through the key
issues of relationships to ensure that
success in love
need not be a matter of good luck for
more
click the link now